[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña desde madrid españa a rocío
garcía torres doctora en psicología
psicoterapeuta de familia y profesora de
grado en psicología de la universidad de
villanueva el tema es la adicción a la
internet y las redes sociales doctora
gracias y en pandemia nos hemos vuelto
aún más dependientes de las herramientas
online para trabajar y con el
aislamiento y la ansiedad a tope es más
frecuente que aumente el tiempo en redes
sociales cómo encontrar un equilibrio
sano en el consumo digital
así es no vivimos en la edad de la
tecnología y desafortunadamente muchas
veces se hace un mal uso de estos
avances tecnológicos que tanta que tanta
ayuda nos ofrecen el tema de la pandemia
ha sido tremendo el confinamiento y la
falta de contactos sociales de planes
hemos podido hacer muchas menos cosas y
ese es el problema que vivimos en un
momento en una era en la que necesitamos
compulsivamente hacer no da la sensación
de que muchas personas se han
descompensado en estos confinamientos en
estos encierros involuntarios en casa y
el enfrentarse a ellos mismos el tener
tiempo para pensar para sentir y se le
ha hecho pasar muy mal y esto ha hecho
que haya habido un abuso
un abuso muchas veces sin llegar a la
adicción no un abuso realmente de estos
de estas tecnologías de las redes
sociales para refugiar nos en esa
gratificación inmediata en ese refugio
en esa anestesia que suponen las
tecnologías y las redes sociales para
nuestras emociones y para las
sensaciones desagradables que hemos
vivido en todo este tiempo así es
bueno y entonces cuando se puede decir
doctora que una persona es adicta a las
redes cuáles son las señales de alerta y
qué es lo que hay que hacer
bueno al final pasar de la busca a la
adicción parece que está en una línea
fina porque al final el abuso es algo
que como decíamos está en nuestros días
es algo muy frecuente
esa tendencia compulsiva a entretenernos
no obtener una gratificación inmediata
pero la adicción llega cuando hay una
pérdida de control cuando la persona
realmente no es capaz de dejar de
meterse en una red social no es capaz de
dejar de tener contacto con las personas
a través de redes sociales no ha
abandonado otras esferas de su vida como
la académica en el caso de los
adolescentes que es lo que nos ocupa el
ámbito laboral cuando la higiene del
sueño de la alimentación realmente se
ven mermadas por este uso por este abuso
por esta adicción a la sustancia cuando
hay un síndrome de abstinencia uno cree
y bing que la persona siente que sin
tener contacto con esa fuente
tecnológica con esa red social siente
malestar le cuesta conciliar el sueño
está irritable siente disforia pues hay
un montón de señales que nos van a
avisar de que realmente
fina de la bus a la adicción la estamos
pudiendo pasar y ahí es cuando los
padres y al final yo como como terapeuta
de familia lo veo mucho en consulta como
los padres tenemos el derecho y la
obligación de poder acompañar a nuestros
hijos en este proceso poder velar porque
realmente no llegan a negar este
problema porque no porque no mientan no
muchas veces cuando nos enfrentamos
adolecentes que están mintiendo que
están ocultando este este mal uso de las
tecnologías pues tenemos también hay un
indicio y al final pues ayudarles a los
adolescentes a que hagan un buen uso de
estas tecnologías a que utilicen las
redes sociales en espacios comunes a que
vigilemos el tiempo que dedican a estas
redes sociales estas tecnologías no que
siempre el dispositivo sea adecuado al
momento evolutivo del niño son muchas
las cosas que podemos hacer para que un
abuso no termine nada dije 'no por no
hablar de la importancia que tiene la
educación para que no se llegue a ésta
esta situación de abuso este mal uso de
las tecnologías que tanto bien nos hacen
en estos nuestros tiempos
estar alerta en lo primero entonces y ya
para el cierre le quiero preguntar muy
rápidamente qué tan reales son las
conexiones que se crean a través de
internet estamos perdiendo un componente
de salud emocional viendo por ejemplo
historias de 15 segundos en vez de
sostener conversaciones en persona o
conversaciones en tiempo real bueno es
tremendo nos seguro que a todos nos
suena esta escena en la que estamos en
un café en la que estamos comiendo
cenando con alguien en la persona que
tenemos enfrente lejos de mirar nos está
en el teléfono viendo se ha obtenido un
like o si alguien ha contestado alguna
historia entonces el vínculo muchas
veces está empobreciendo porque no
estamos centrándonos en esa conexión que
en ese momento tenemos que trabajar y
que elaborar con la persona que tenemos
delante y no olvidar que a pesar del
confinamiento y de esto y este momento
difícil
la distancia es física no es emocional o
sea que estas redes sociales y estas
tecnologías pueden pueden suponer una
ayuda para poder realmente poder tener
este vínculo y que no se pierda a pesar
de la distancia gracias a ustedes
doctora que tenga un feliz día y a
ustedes
televidentes sigan en france 24 ya
cultivar relaciones sadam sanas en la
red
[Música]